[Music]
a hundred percent like like i always do
that
it's who i am it's why i win you'll
never trick the market
this portion is like with me so i think
this is when you need to get selfish
like you need to ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast
that's how you get [ __ ] done that's when
you figure stuff out this
is the television and the television
is the radio so forties [ __ ]
there we go there we go hi everybody
buddy
hey buddy how you doing really good
let's do the intros
hi gary super excited and nervous
um so yeah we basically we're husband
and wife team
and we restore classic buses and coaches
so and we also collect them ourselves as
well so yeah that's us
i love that buses and coaches
yeah like you know like the london root
master
i love it i love it i love it
i love it welcome i'm looking forward to
it and now we're going over to alberta
we've got calgary jeff humphries jeff
say hi to gary
hey gary how's it going um i'm well jeff
how are you
good thank you uh jeff humphreys like
joe said calgary alberta big flames fan
building a personal brand and run my own
uh little digital agency office that's
kind of my primary uh business
well good news i've got a little bit of
understanding of that world so looking
forward to helping
thanks man let's keep moving and uh
coming into the states but down to
arizona we've got anthony say hi to gary
anthony
gee what's up brother how are you i'm
really well and how are you
coming up to chicago we've got deuce
from sweet baby ray's
goose say hi to gary hey gary been
following you a long time man really
good to meet you nice to meet you um
i'm a chef my uh family my dad actually
created sweet baby raise
and we have a restaurant and a catering
business we sold the rights to the sauce
to ken's foods
so but we retain the rights to use the
name for restaurants and catering so
it's kind of a weird i understand
i know no it's not a weird it's actually
more common than you think i know i
understand that quite a bit
so so my big question well we'll get to
that but that's
i i run the business now we have a
catering and a small restaurant
and um got it got some questions
i love it brother real pleasure and then
the closest
to home literally we've got alex over in
new york who's a liquor store owner
yeah hey so uh yeah i own a liquor store
uh now actually like one and a half
liquor stores and i am
trying to figure out yeah bill how did
you make out uh
where james could you go on but please
how to make the next step uh basically
i've been dabbling in
maybe helping other liquor store owners
grow their business and
uh yeah i'm at a crossroads where do i
do i
or grow other people's stores for money
we'll get it we'll get into that in a
minute
awesome i'm really excited but just to
reiterate what i'm sure joe or
james or mickey or sydney or this is the
time to go very selfish
you know very specific questions uh but
before we get into that how's how's it
been going so far
anecdotally little quick comments or
head nods or body language
how's uh how's 4ds going for everybody
so far good
awesome good awesome all right joe
orchestrate me who's first question
i'm ready to rock the uk so ashton
kirsten the revivist
go ahead y'all okay so
first question is how do we generate
more interest in classic buses and
coaches
um in an aging sort of industry where a
lot of the clients
are older should we sidestep into the
classic car world that's got a more
cool vibe um or should i are you
are you are you willing to yeah
yeah definitely like you like that idea
that's not like you're doing it just
because that's where you think the
businesses
you need to go like it would equally be
interesting to you if you went into that
world
um well we would want to generate
interest from classic car owners
to the buses
that does make sense are you okay if
what's gonna happen which i think would
naturally happen
like market size matters
right and so like if you're doing the
classic car thing
just to use it as a gateway drug to get
people to love
something you love you can't make people
love
something you love outside of sharing
your passion
yeah if if you like the refurbishing and
all the cool [ __ ] that comes along with
it finding it the thrill of the hunt all
the [ __ ] that i
like it's funny there's many people in
here who literally do what i've done my
whole life and my career yet
it's your business that i probably most
excited about
because i'm such a collector so i love
nfts like you know so if
you love the classic car thing or
if the buggies bus is like you know like
coaches like
if that's a hundred and the classic car
is an 85 or a 90 or even an
80 out of 100 point scale of passion and
happiness
i would do that tomorrow because that's
healthier for your business
yeah because it's a much bigger market
size and you have less
fighting to get people to give a [ __ ]
yeah yeah i think i think
would you focus on getting like the gen
z into buses and coaches even though
they don't remember them
because they're older things you won't
be able to pull that off
no that's not to enough scale that's
that's good to hear okay but i but i
think if you did the classic cars thing
and also passionately talked about
buses and buggies and coaches that
over time you'll get three to seven
percent of that base to give a [ __ ]
and that's far more than you would have
if you just tried
to get got it i see it yeah yeah so
totally got it
so second question real quick sir um
what do you think about the format of
traditional museums
so there's like bust museums um our
pop-up experiences
virtual um museum collaborations with
the influencers the way forwards
you know would you go to a bus museum
because there's a lot of pain around
that for the museums that like how we're
going to get people in the door
you mean because of cobit or even in the
macro even in the
in the macro because it obviously it's
like an aging industry again
yeah i don't like museums as a as a
pop-up experiences so i like like a food
fair
that that is mixed with the bus like you
need another trigger
right so it's almost like you know yeah
you almost call like burg
you create a festival a one day event
called burgers and buses
where you have a burger competition and
the buses are there
and you start got it collateral you're
in the osmosis business nobody's going
to come in
just to come in but through osmosis you
might be able to
okay yeah awesome and thank you and the
final question
we hope you love is what are your
thoughts on classic vehicle collecting
and nfts
oh cute i mean nfts are going to be like
websites everybody will have one
and natural collecting places is a great
place i think there's really really big
things there
you should absolutely get very serious
about it ft's okay
right but remember when when you launch
yours if you launch yours
care about the audience more than the
money you make because everyone's
[ __ ] up right now because it's just a
land grab for cash
and that's why most are going to be bad
okay
awesome thank you so much gary
cool thanks uh over to jeff jeff over in
calgary
thanks joe um yeah man gary it's super
cool to actually be talking to you face
to face i've been uh
on your train for i told everyone for
about 13 years now
my um my last job i worked in a
restaurant company with 100 restaurants
in north america i ran all the digital
marketing for them and
the only reason i got that job is
because i found you and and
you know listen to what you're up to and
and saw the the value
and now that i've left that company and
started my own agency
17 months ago and it's actually been
successful which has been really cool
thanks to your blueprint
so what i'm up to dude is i'm
essentially taking your blueprint on on
making a personal brand and running
and and i'm like i said 17 months in um
and yeah it's just so i get it i get it
and it seems like you've been you know
many people consume me
very few get it even fewer
get it and do something about it so
you've given me enough context that you
are in that third small bucket so now
let's kind of go to the 301 course
right totally what's confusing
i feel like you've got it so this is
even more fun like give me the question
like what's the question like what's the
thing you don't see
or what's hard there's two questions and
i'm afraid of the answer
because it might be patience but um the
you know when to hire
and how do i get more clients when to
hire
is is much earlier than you think
try to make as little money as possible
like to
like right after this tonight okay this
is what i'm seeing with my business
how little can i live on for the next
two years like the way i built wine
library and vaynermedia was exactly the
same i paid myself
very little for a long time for wine
library forever for vayner
you know after buying out my brother and
other things like
i but i still feel under compensated for
the executive i am
always take as little as possible
because that will let you hire quicker
which will let you build faster and and
do you think it's um
uh hire a production person you know a
creative that can do graphic design
maybe some copywriting you know if they
got the video game like
that person to create content at scale
or do you think that's what's your
biggest what's your biggest pain point
right now
account or or output uh
output so let's say you know i got eight
clients and you know if i'm creating
content for them plus my personal brand
i feel they output me
to me absolutely create what we would
call creators
video or picture or written word but i'd
also be very thoughtful about bringing
an account person immediately
so that you're not dealing with the
clients right
because that's where you get strained on
those ends
makes sense so one of each one of each
and i'd probably go account
and freelance the creative if you didn't
have the means to do both
then i would do both immediately if you
can get to a place where you can afford
to go
to that place and the freelance game is
definitely a good option hey like i
could find a young talented
graphic designer kind of person that
could you know just you'd be stuck yeah
there's so many people out there
you can do a lot okay so okay got it
um and obviously the cliche the cliche
question of like how do you find more
clients is there really
well i think i think i think you figured
this out i think anthony's coming up
like like
i think brand yeah brand is how you get
clients and you're going down personal
brand
a couple others here are going to do it
like but i think you need the
creators and the one account person
because what you're now at is you're at
mass with eight clients
and you're stuck yeah yeah completely
yeah like my the weeks just go by or i'm
just like servicing
i didn't get to this correct i didn't
get a new client i didn't put out more
content for myself
you need to drive down the cost of your
people
so the two people you hire you need to
make them as low as possible
and there's people out there that can do
that they're either well off or they're
they're on two sides of the coin their
parents are super rich and they can do
it
or they're super hungry and they don't
give a [ __ ] and they're like us and
they're willing to just grind for it
they're out there you got to spend all
your time fixing the weld not the sink
you're in a hamster wheel
you take a step out like you're doing
today brilliant honestly
take a step out now you need to act on
this step out
you need to live on linkedin and on your
own social and calling friends going to
your address book on your phone and
hitting up old friends you know anybody
who's willing to
and get a designer copywriter and
a account person immediately
yeah that makes sense it it yeah and
it's just coming up with that the number
you know the metric
how much can i live on and correct and
then run the map backwards that's it
yeah and then like and then if you're
desperate and you're hungry you start
selling chachkas
you know like like you just start
selling [ __ ]
like sell a [ __ ] flames piece of
memorabilia like you fight for it you'll
buy it back in a couple years like
you know it's not just you know first
it's how rough am i willing to live
truly yeah like i was willing to live
super rough
like i've always lived below my means
for
investment in my businesses and that's
it i've listened to you say that over
and over and it
and and what's been interesting is i
talk to different people about
you know they might not be business
owners and i'm 17 months in and i'm
thinking about hiring somebody people
think i'm crazy because
the a they're like how are you doing
this i needed i needed a little
reinforcement of that that's where this
is supposed to go i think you're too
late at eight
i think you should have hired at f4 yeah
because
everybody wants this fast brother yeah
um and and and you know building the
personal brand idea i
launched a pretty trick podcast super
cool room you know it's got all the
production value it looks slick
so you know i'm trying to build my brand
out to get access to different people
instead of you know
i go through my rolodex once and say hey
i'm i offer all these services and here
it's crickets right nothing comes back
so is there you know is there any ways
to
amplify that link linkedin
heavily linkedin also startup calgary
biz small business group
on facebook immediately call it the
calgary
small business association
and just like live on and just start
[ __ ]
networking it spamming people on
like businesses on in calgary on
facebook and be like you should join
this
host the party for small business talk
that will lead the business
just let them and just and keep it
focused on digital marketing and just
kind of host the digital marketing party
partners anything no
no no you talk about digital marketing
but just say business because you're
more than a digital marketer you just
went through 17 months of starting a
business yeah the lonely days
the the doubt they didn't know how to
open a bank account who the [ __ ] knows
right all of it all of it brother i know
it i lived it
is there um is there a way to actually
go fishing for
um clients with bigger budgets right now
let's say i'm kind of mom and pop you
know if
my monthly retainer is like 19.50 a
month is there a way to
ratchet by messaging people on linkedin
and asking them if they you know want to
join
your pod be a guest on your podcast yeah
to talk about marketing which they'll
say yes to
and then that leads to the business
development great
that makes sense um is there any um
any mis any mistakes or
issues like is there anything i should
be aware of as i'm growing this thing
that i
you know i shouldn't do anything or yep
don't run out of cash
you're doing too many things well you
need to figure out how low you can go
yeah live that life for three years
hire people fire them when they're wrong
because the
kryptonite here is you hire someone for
account and they're bad and you're like
god but i [ __ ] need this person to
know
fire rehire that's it
that's it um that's it and just keep on
you know the charging when i'm charging
things out joe just tell me if i'm
talking too much
um charging if i'm charging things out i
just keep on
bumping it up every month and seeing
until they say no you're listening too
much brother
i do listen so you're listening too much
you got it okay
it's um and on the personal on the
personal branding side
he's still there is it gone dead i'm
here okay cool
uh sorry on the personal branding side
is there a way to amplify
my message so the hack that i've done is
i interviewed calgary's biggest dj
and put them on the podcast clipped
clipped a 10 second
moment out put it up advertised on
facebook and instagram targeted towards
people in calgary
in an age range that are interested in
that style of music
and you know and and yeah i got 200
views on youtube and you know it's the
biggest
it was the biggest um or most
well-received podcast
you are you are so deep in my blueprint
like i'm almost i'm genuinely bored at
this point okay
you've no no no i'm saying that as a
huge compliment you got this
higher immediately the two big
breakthroughs i'm giving you is
live like [ __ ] for two like start
cutting
expenses yeah in your real life
yeah like less on food like
like don't do anything don't buy
anything yeah sell some [ __ ] that's
laying around the house like
i'm not [ __ ] kidding you just do it
that that that's my girl that's my
growth my next
move right there good all right
well we may get some more okay let's go
ahead go down to scottsdale and talk to
anthony
anthony
you're on with g g thanks again bro we
spoke at a ypo event not too long ago
you told me to send out a text message
within 24 hours i made 120 grand in
three hours so
thanks for the tip brother uh why don't
why don't you why don't you why don't
you tell everybody what that is
because that might just help a couple of
people on here 100
you just so uh you know i had people
call in and customers past customers but
i wasn't texting them
um or doing anything you just talked
about how the contact rate was like over
90
at least for me it was a 10 conversion
rate on these texts
and you're just like dude you open every
text you get don't you and i was like oh
yeah no [ __ ] duh
so you're like okay just like how you
told the last guy 24 hours dude what are
you gonna [ __ ] do to act on it
instead of just taking this in phone me
like
dope good info so i said okay cool i
load it up i literally sign up for a
software it took me
less than an hour to set it up shot it
out the next morning and literally
between 9 a.m and noon we made 120 grand
just
one single tax going out to everyone
who's ever called us before uh just
saying hey you know
it was basically like hey uh you know
open enrollments ending soon give us a
call right now here's the phone number
like it was
[ __ ] nothingness took an hour made
over six figures in three hours so
thank you so everybody the more people
you can get into text with you the
better
just keep that in mind with every
special platform
you may need to get a separate number if
you don't like having a lot of text
interviewed with your life
there's software as anthony's speaking
to but like text what uh what i'm going
to tell you
is very very very important what if
you're going to build a personal brand
as an arbitrage the only reason
i am where i'm at is that i've never
looked the other way
for my own self-interest and i'm coming
and i can feel i can tell you you can
feel this is coming from a really good
place
promise me that you're going to really
look in the mirror and say
what have i tricked or convinced myself
for convenience because it's my business
and what what is that you know because
everyone has that line that's life
i'll tell you why there's no hiding
when you build a personal brand so what
i want to make sure you know you're
walking into if you're going to amplify
a personal brand in a space that has a
brand issue
the you have no prayer of succeeding
you're only going to get more [ __ ] on
unless you [ __ ]
own it own it own it
yeah i really appreciate you saying that
because yeah my question was basically
i've been hiding from it so i don't
nobody actually knows you know correct
and so and so what i'm worried about
is you've got to promise me
that the three things that you've made
up
excuses justifications trick
your own self that you completely
unravel that
if that's a death blow to the business
itself i'm telling you right now
that a personal brand is only going to
accelerate anxiety nothing else
if if if you c if you can own it
address it with how you do business and
then come out and say yes this is the
game
second right now 99 of nft products
are gonna fail because i see all the bad
behavior and i have to because i think
nft's gonna be huge so i have to
massively say that
because i believe it but i have to over
communicate all the pitfalls because i
don't need somebody saying you [ __ ]
made me buy
this nft for four thousand dollars and
it went to nine dollars it was beanie
babies because
i know it to be true and and i would
never
tarnish my name for that you can't
trick people it's not how life works so
you need to think but you can trick
yourself
got it and so i'm getting real from the
[ __ ] heart advice right now
yep you gotta you you've got it you got
it bro and by the way
either is okay everything's okay
anything can be okay
but i can tell you right now you will be
snuffed out
and it and that will be amplified and
it'll be bad
and so you have to at all [ __ ] costs
be
100 the only person you could be naked
with is yourself
you have to this is like the value of
this entire interaction get naked
with yourself no [ __ ] tricking
yourself
see if you can compromise like not
compromise
collateralize that and say okay
i can never get over this hump the world
knows it's not good and honestly if i'm
naked like gary told me to it isn't good
what do i do now because if you go
personal brand you'll get destroyed
if you're bad sure makes totally
different okay so on that
you know i hear you and the nft thing
that 99
uh makes sense for me too especially if
i'm like hey it's gonna [ __ ] up your
credit score but
that it helps in this way but i i hear
what you're saying yeah it's like it's
yeah
like if you're like hey because you
could flip this you know that right
it's like being the prisoner that
becomes fbi you can flip it yeah
i mean like here it [ __ ] is there
this is the right
with media transparency in the
advertising space
you know 100 i did
yeah 100 like like i always do that it's
who i
am it's why i win you'll never trick the
market
so when i see something strict in the
market i don't try to trick the market
and make a quick buck
i try to [ __ ] expose it
and have the long-term legacy
i love that okay that's what i did in
the wine world
i did in the wine world right like
people were overpaying
lines anyway go ahead brother
oh i appreciate that that was extremely
more beneficial than
uh that's exactly that that
that's the game and
nobody gets to tell somebody how to live
life you do you
but don't trick yourself into thinking
you can thread the needle on the
personal brand thing in
a space that has this much you know
damage to it
unless you go in guns are blazing full
naked
which may hurt you in some short-term
revenue
but will help you long-term and by the
way like friend a friend
you'll feel so much better every day
there's no cloud
i love that brother and i guess um
question on that to segue that so we're
an affiliate right just like lending
tree
you're driving send a custom customer to
a guy when they're gone
do you have any thoughts or ideas on how
to bridge the gap of
reoccurring revenue and or increasing
the lifetime value when right now i
basically you call in off my app
right i send you brand brand
you know your game is all about brand
the way you'll you'll
increase is that people just default
thinking to you which will decrease
your arb funnels like google and other
things brand
always wins the end got it and and
my question would be okay so if i've got
aggressive advertising that goes back to
our first conversation we just had
and you've got to build brands not you
got to build brand not just sales
funnels from
sales dr toll booth google life you need
to build brand
vaynermedia doesn't get a trillion leads
because
i've got i don't do any dr marketing i'm
not even sure
i could look right now on [ __ ]
youtube and other agencies are probably
buying vaynermedia and we're not even
buying it like
it's [ __ ] brand i'm following
makes total sense last question if you
don't mind uh
personal brand so the growth no shock to
our first conversation
isn't correlated to my uh uh business
right like i'm not talking about how to
get out of debt or auto insurance or
anything like that
um if i don't have direct monetization
my personal brand but i know it's the
importance of investing
in it do you have any i guess uh
just common thoughts suggestions
comments on that at all yeah
i got a great one look welcome to brand
you're so stuck being sales transaction
you just described brand
i can't talk about anything you got it
brother
you literally just described the brand
you're just so binary right like it
makes sense you're
you know you're math you're black and
white yeah and i'm saying brother
gray is the answer it was that was
beautiful what you just said
you just actually described brandt
thank you you know what's so funny
somebody yeah i had an incredible
meeting that i want to tell everybody
here because it's going to help
similar concept the guy was all mad at
it
thinks that i was full of [ __ ] and he
says to me gary you don't
and i knew the guy and then i let me
phrase it's not true
i knew of the guy but he shows up to the
meaning with the biggest
cross on his chest that you've ever seen
in jewelry form
so i take that social cue i've got a
sense
right i knew a little bit about him you
know him being a man of faith which was
cool which i love
but he had a huge [ __ ] cross right
and he goes gary the problem is i
believe in things i can touch
he was talking my math he goes what you
talk about i can't touch
i can't believe in it and so i finally
took a little bit of a barrage from him
i said can i ask you a question he goes
sure i go do you believe in god
he goes are you [ __ ] kidding me i go
you're not touching god
yeah that's brand i believe in brand
more than any math anybody here shows me
because i know that's how the world
actually works
and that's what you need to win on
got it cool thank you very much i'll run
with vegan speaking of iconic brands
deuce sweet baby raise let's go
uh you're on mute deuce
cool oh gary i've been thinking about
asking you this question for a long time
because i
nobody can give me the answer and i'm
like gary's going to have it in the back
of his head
so i got to give you a little context
okay
we opened the barbecue restaurant in
2005
naturally we started doing catering
because people wanted backyard barbecues
picnics
grew into weddings we bought a higher
end catering brand a smaller like
million dollar boutique catering company
called true cuisine
so now we have sweet baby raised
catering a barbecue restaurant sweet
baby raise and true cuisine
so now we're running two different
brands sweet baby raised catering and
true cuisine catering
a couple years later we bought a big
event planning company
because we're gonna do everything we'll
do your lights your staging
your food everything i got it okay
so we've created the sbr events group
meeting house the event company would
did not work out it was a bad
partnership situation so that's gone so
now we still have
the sweet baby raised catering true
cuisine catering and the barbecue
restaurant
i don't know what is the best way to
market for a long-term future
do you want the whole cr the whole thing
the three parts right
yes can i just call the whole thing sbr
events group
and roll it into one the reason we got
true cuisine is because
stick stick with me do you because
you're right i do i do have the answer
um let me tell you the path of how
you're going to answer it with my help
okay to whom
okay so many people waste so much energy
on things that either already been
solved
or are based on some ideology they have
for themselves
that means nothing to the customer right
so so let's work backwards you've got
three entities you've got three entities
right
right and possibly fourth what deuce is
wild but that's a different conversation
you've got four entities yeah right
let's i don't care what you corporately
call them nord is really the b2b world
the only thing you care we care about is
who's making decisions the customer
right
right so obviously for the restaurant
you're not going to change the name
because it's the [ __ ] restaurant and
it's been there forever right
yeah the two catering businesses
right you ask yourself
how strong are those brands individually
right what's deuces wild deuces wild
is sauces and rubs it's it's what i
developed
uh barbecue sauce got it got it
and that could be a restaurant brand too
potentially do you know
do you know what the corporate entity
that houses wine library is called
my dad's business no it's called
stecklin and walker inc
my dad bought it the small little store
in 1983
from joe walker and jerry stecklin
it is called stecklin and walker inc
the only thing that matters is that the
brand is wine library and that's what
people know
right deuces wild the restaurant and the
two
front-facing catering brands that people
know and use and word about the round
should all keep their names okay and
whatever the [ __ ] you want to hold call
the holding company
in the back doesn't matter do you think
people here even know if procter gamble
owns tide
or head and shoulders is unilever or
that sunkist is owned by coca-cola
nobody gives a [ __ ]
you give a [ __ ]
so i guess my question is then
with the true cuisine brand that's like
our higher end catering
and and all of it together is like where
i fall
where i have the problem with it then i
have to market all of it i have to
social media all of it i have to
of course you do they're different
customers anyway
right okay you're trying to change the
brands
of brands that have value because of the
marketing execution
instead of the reverse
okay you're trying you're looking for
efficiencies
yes in i love you i love you this is so
fun
you're looking for efficiencies by
diluting the thing that
is the only [ __ ] thing you have
okay you need to triple down on building
out all those things
okay you can have one person at the top
at the group level be the head of
marketing
and then the individual four people that
do content for the four things
report into so you can have some
cohesiveness you can switch around
people the
third biggest business has the best
person let's put her on the first
business
you can have a little corporate there
but
you need to market the brands unless you
want to change all the brands
but you don't want to do that because
the high-end brand has its equity in
that name for the high end
right yeah the fancy brides don't want
sweet baby rays to cater their weddi
go figure yeah
um awesome well you definitely helped
out a lot for sure with that
and uh i want you to come to chicago and
have some barbecue gary
there you go i'm a hundred percent
committing right now james rorsini will
keep me honest
yes yes all right yeah
um bailey deuce mainly because i want to
take this clip and then when i put your
restaurant on my vlog when i'm there
it'll show that i'm a man of my word so
i'm looking forward to it once the world
opens up all right let's wrap this up
alex yeah alex go ahead
text them uh so
it goes without saying gary i i've got
like a million questions that i could
ask you about the liquor store business
uh
but i guess um you know i've been
thinking about the past few days
i'm just gonna go with what i prefaced
earlier so i just want to tell you a
little bit uh basically i grew up in the
store
right uh my parents both came from
poland very uh uh with nothing basically
and they they were able to buy
into a store uh when i was about six
give me 13 seconds i apologize give me
13 seconds
you got it just arrived at destination
yeah it's getting ready to get that
vaccine oh no [ __ ]
yeah i'm getting the vaccine i'm pretty
excited all right go ahead brother
pretty excited that's
interesting so uh
grew up you know working in there never
really planned on staying in the
business uh
i went to college after college i uh
figured let's go
i saved up some money went to poland
trying to basically figure out how to
make money online
and uh that never really happened so
after basically two years i came back
with
my now wife moved back in with my
parents
and convinced them to uh yeah let me uh
run that liquor store for them
and um so that was about three years ago
when i was 24. and so since then
you know i've been able to basically
like brute force it from uh
1.2 million to uh last year we closed at
4.5 million
you know wow yep yeah so it's going
pretty well uh
also last it's been [ __ ] brutal
honestly uh you know
i just i've been on cod for since
basically uh january
just got off this week but um i also
why because because because you got
caught because demand
started to sway a little bit like as
people kind of got back a little bit
why would you have cod no did you get
over your steez or you got one bad deal
that [ __ ] you
up because i know this is so well i'm
just curious it's kind of like uh
a pattern i i was on cod for a bunch of
months last year as well
uh but basically this december was the
first time i almost did a
we did like 700 thousand dollars in
december right and a lot of that was
shipping
yeah we crushed but i over ordered and
um that makes sense makes sense yeah
fair enough keep going so um last month
i i closed
on a liquor store my own because that
one's my under my dad's name you know
new york you can only have yeah of
course
license of course so now i've got this
linbrook wine in liquor which honestly i
plan on just kind of selling that
um you know hopefully sooner than later
within like six months
to a year you bought you bought it to
flip it
i i bought it because i've been wanting
to buy a store
for a while you know and so it was a
good deal it was really cheap it was
like a hundred thousand dollars all in
so yeah i want to basically flip it and
then uh and so i know i'm gonna have a
bunch of money
you know hopefully by next year to to
invest in something
cool uh that being said i also started
doing
some youtube videos uh like two years
ago uh basically for liquor store owners
and it's just off the cuff kind of
like giving advice and stuff and so uh
it was pretty boring in the beginning
but now at this point you know i'm
getting
emails and and calls and stuff people
actually coming to the store and stuff
and uh
appreciating you know other liquor store
owners who really like go out of their
way to thank me
for for providing that that info for
them and so
it's um it's been on my head you know i
know that i've i've got to continue both
probably both in the liquor store
business just because i've already got
that head start
and you know i'm patient enough i can i
can wait another 10 years before i can
make money with uh you know yeah running
you've got it
you've got it very figured out you can
easily do both
easily sure and so uh so what do you
think gary uh
i came up with alex flicinski.com you
know it's it's all like uh i took some
course on how to make a course and
you know that sounds funny but uh the
the course is pretty much there i'm
ready to start
calling people and have people pay me to
help them
improve their liquor store businesses
and i'm curious what do you think
do you think that i should push hard to
make money up front or should i just
keep providing uh
you know these free videos and and spend
more time on on that as far as the
personal brand
side of things go everyone's different
my preference is that you don't go for
scale because they're not specific and
they're
and that you do more hand to hand combat
and do bigger retainers
i'd rather you have like two clients
paying you 50 000
each for the year than sell a hundred
courses
because every time somebody pays
for a course to learn how to do courses
they [ __ ] up their brand
sure yeah okay
that's super binary i'd rather you focus
on your business
build up the liquor store so it's flips
keep building your parents one get a
second one
again on your own name after you sell
one make it bigger and better
and keep making the videos and
get somebody to really pay you as a
consultant like
50k for the year 100k you know nice
little bag
and keep building and learning how one
of the things all of us have learned
jeff i'm sure you learned this about
yourself as you made your transition
and others here all of us have way more
capacity than we thought we did
like you used to think you were busy
remember everybody when you used to
think you were busy
and then you got way busier remember
that like no matter what it is for all
of us
everyone here my team is like just the
way it is
i'm sure for joe and james when they
came into my company like the speed and
like it's different
it's like you could humans can do more
than they think
and so you'll figure that out as you'll
have
four stores one in your wife's name like
and consulting seven
and you're still just 28 or 29 30 31 32
like
i would keep going down that path
because cause people
don't triple down on what they got going
that's working they think they need to
go to some new thing
like i hear your story alex and then the
next line is like and now gary i'm gonna
be a crypto
trader and i'm like why like [ __ ]
back to
you know patience and like strategy and
it alex it's flatter
you know how happy i am that people can
hear my story because i'm sure for you
just a little bit because we have so
many similarities
of our backgrounds and heritage and
everything it probably is exciting for
you to hear like me say
hey i was 34 and i was still in liquor
store i had no [ __ ] money like
it gives hope to like you know right it
gives hope and i think it's
here's the good news it's true how old
are you now 27.
yeah i'm really loving it the corporate
name for the store is actually triple
down inc
i don't know why but i love it and i i
was thinking
maybe the next store is going to be in
uh actually new jersey
um it doesn't have to do with you it has
to do more with the fact of the
you know expanding uh if i do continue
100
or you know i mean i mean this i mean
the second you do that i'm going to
start getting very feisty and trying to
put you out of business
i uh i think i think that's awesome bro
and i think you can
look this is an industry where you
figured out you could do real damage
and it's a great base i lived it you
know it changed my parents life like i
know what their lifestyle is compared to
what it was
it's a good industry if you have the
talent and i think consulting other
people is good training
some people will say it's distraction
you should focus on your own
i actually think it's good training
because you're going to learn new
patterns that you wouldn't have had in
your own business
you're going to learn [ __ ] from another
business that you're going to apply to
your business
it's there's something there you're
still in your 20s i like where you're
going do both
youtube watch what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you